what else do you like to sing ariana
grande i am a huge ariana grande fan the
biggest fan obsessed with you oh my gosh
she even came with a ponytail
ariana grande is making her coaching
debut on the voice and let's just say
more than a few contestants are total
orientators it's the most fun i've ever
had in my whole life the first look for
season 21 just dropped and ariana takes
her seat alongside fellow coaches kelly
clarkson blake shelton and john legend
but it's not just the contestants who
are big re fans it's the crowd and
coaches too is everybody in here just
obsessed with ariana you have no chance
push it back push it back
[Applause]
kelly what are your thoughts with ariana
grande joining my thoughts are this is
my last chance to win the voice
no i'm a huge fan of her voice i love
her voice i've only run into her a
couple times and she's so sweet like
every time we run into each other so i'm
just a fan i i would love like as a
person that's competed in a show like
this i would love to be able to pick a
you know someone like her she sings so
beautifully and is um just killing it
still in the charts like she's just an
amazing coach like to have on the show
so i think it's going to be really cool
and fun and i like female energy so and
it wouldn't be the voice without some
playful competition i would love to work
with you it would be so fun it would be
an honor thrilled by your performance
pick team legend
yeah that's ariana's own red button that
plays her iconic song thank you next
[Music]
[Applause]
and it seems ariana is already settling
in well and not giving into blake's
notorious reputation as a competitive
coach ariana's the new coach here and
i'm extending an olive branch when i'm
not in the mix i'm trying to help the
kid out hey that's ariana grande look
how awesome she is by the way what's
happening why is it being nice never
trusted i don't
[Applause]
and that's something former coach nick
jonas echoed to e.t in may i think the
best thing to do is just not to trust
blake
shelton
don't just a word he says he's a liar
if you know that stepping into it you'll
be fine but the reigning champ is
unbothered because he has only one
mission they asked me to give you a
piece of advice but i'm not going to
because i could care less if you do well
on this show it's my job to beat you i'm
making it my
mission not to lose in any way shape or
form to ariana
[Music]